Was für eine mondfinsternis oder eben besser was für ein blut mond und ich habe euch ja gebeten mir fotos zu schicken und es waren
unmengen ich wollte sie hier eigentlich unter dem community posten aber da hätte ich wohl mit
zuges band deshalb jetzt das video hier und es sind wirklich spektakuläre fotos angefangen bei ganz normalen handy fotos bis zu wirklich
unglaublichen hammer fotos die mit dem teleskop gemacht wurden also los gehts klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Erstmal vielen vielen dank für die zahlreichen fotos die mich über whatsapp und die anderen messenger erreicht haben
damit hätte ich echt nicht gerechnet die clique und community hat jemand ein hammer projekt hingelegt und vielen dank an alle die mir dann auch
die erlaubnis gegeben haben die fotos zu veröffentlichen gestern abend war es soweit so ungefähr je nachdem wo man war um etwa
21 uhr langsam schob sich der erdschatten vor dem mond fritze finn hat hier ein klasse bild gemacht wie sich der erdschatten
hier vor den mond schiebt er noch ist er hellgrau das sonnenlicht das direkt von der sonne kommt ist noch zu stark dann aber liegt
der mond schon bald komplett im erdschatten und nur licht das durch die erdatmosphäre
gebrochen wird und hier sind die rot anteile viel stärker das trifft auf dem mond es ist so eingetreten wie vermutet das himmelsspektakel
dauerte mit 103 minuten eine ungewöhnlich lange zeit so was wird in diesem jahrhundert nicht mehr geben um
21.20 etwa ist die mondscheibe dann komplett vom erdschatten bedeckt ob jetzt ist der typisch blutrote
riesengroße mond zu bewundern in diesem zustand wird der mond auch als blutmond bezeichnet übrigens wagram und eben nicht besonders
groß was man an den vielen handy bildern sieht aber er wirkt groß wenn er zum beispiel hier über der dresdner frauenkirche
zu sehen ist danke an lena arnold für diese tolle aufnahme im zweiten bild von ihr ist daran auch so richtig blutrote
es war sogar der kleinste vollmond des jahres denn er hat auf seiner bahn um die erde gerade den größten
abstand zu uns und das ist auch die erklärung für die lange dauer der mondfinsternis
weil der mond so weil er weiter weg ist länger im erdschatten ist aber ganz besonders war dann das
erscheinen das maß der dank jetzt viel dunklere mondes richtig gut zu erkennen war und hier sieht man auf dem bild von jahren aus südhessen
so die erdkrümmung unseres globus als schatten auf dem mond was für ein spektakel
hier nochmal die schönsten bilder musik hoch
Ich kann nur sagen gänsehaut pur wenn er in zukunft kein video verpassen wollen dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die
etwas unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube und er verpasst kein video denn wie whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen
täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür da klicken aber nicht die
wenn auch die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufsteht menschen sollen auf dem mond siedeln bis dann
bleibt dran